PAUL CAPONETTI: This is IoT204--
Connected RobotS--
IoT in the Warehouse.
I'm Paul Caponetti.
I'm an IoT solutions
engineer with Google.
CHRISTOPHER CACIOPPO: HI,
I'm Christopher Cacioppo.
I'm the CTO and one of the
co-founders of 6 River Systems.
JOSEPH HUGHES: And I'm
Joseph Hughes, director
of dev ops at 6 River Systems.
PAUL CAPONETTI: We'll be talking
about collaborative robotics
and how it helps companies
meet the ever-changing needs
of today's consumers.
So quick agenda--
I'm going to take
some time initially
to try and frame
some of the problems
that warehouses are
trying to solve today.
I'll also go through some of
the cloud solutions that help.
I'll then hand over
to Chris Cacioppo here
for a double-click
on the business
case for collaborative robotics,
and a little more information
about 6 River Systems.
And then Joe will
finish up with all
of the tech behind 6
River Systems and products
that they offer.
So there is a Dory
for today's session.
And I'm told if
you go to the app
and go to our session IoT204,
you can see a link down below.
Dory is an internal
tool built at Google
that's being made
available at Next.
You can go here to post
your questions for us
while we speak.
You can also see the questions
that others are posting.
You can upvote and downvote
those questions as you see fit.
The idea is at the end
of the presentation,
we'll have a bit of a stacked
ranking of what the audience
wants to hear from us.
We're going to aim to add six
minutes, seven minutes early
to try and get as many of these
questions answered as possible.
And afterward we'll be able
to answer questions offline.
So quick survey so I know
who's in the audience today--
how many people out
there, by show of hands,
are developers,
architects, people
that are building systems?
We have quite a bit.
That's great.
There's definitely
content for you.
How many people are
in the warehouse
space, working with
warehouse management systems?
Show of hands.
Good.
We've got a bunch.
How about robotics,
working with ROS?
Great, there's a
bunch of those too.
How many people have ever
bought a physical product
on the internet?
All right, good.
Captive audience.
So in all seriousness,
this is the audience
that we built the talk for.
Hopefully you find
some of this useful.
So what are the needs
of the warehouse today?
And as an IoT developer
that's been working
on a lot of different
connected products,
working with a lot of
different IoT cloud solutions,
the first thing that strikes
me is the sheer amount
of data available.
So there's products,
there's product locations,
there's LIDAR points.
There's all sorts of things
that without the technology
you have, and now
adding robots you
have things like
batteries, robots statuses,
many, many, many
different types of data.
And as a person that's
managing a warehouse,
I want to know that there's
a way of obtaining this data,
there's a way of reacting
to it, formatting it.
And Google Cloud
has you covered.
If you're able to
connect your Edge devices
and your sensors
to Cloud IoT Core,
you can quickly,
securely, and easily
get that data to the cloud.
From IoT Core, you get
your data into a Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub can act as a
kind of central point
in your cloud architecture.
From there you'd be able
to trigger cloud functions
to react to your data
or data flows, Dataproc,
to be able to transform your
data into an optimal format,
and then ultimately
sync it to BigQuery.
And I say BigQuery.
There's a lot of different
data persistence mechanisms
available on data cloud,
but BigQuery I believe
is uniquely well-suited
to the problems warehouses
are faced with today.
BigQuery is Google's server
data warehouse in the cloud,
and it's built to excel
with analytics workloads.
So let's say you have your
data publishing in the cloud,
you have it formatted, you
have it synced to BigQuery.
You're quickly faced with
the next daunting task.
There's so many things
that you could potentially
change in your warehouse to try
and optimize your pick rates,
or find bottlenecks, or just
overall get your throughput up.
You could potentially
be spending man months
on a part of your system
that, even if done perfectly,
would only shave a
small amount of time
off your average pick
rate, where there
may be a bottleneck elsewhere
that if you spent a couple man
hours you would unlock a whole
bunch more at throughput.
The quickest way to get
to this insight is--
since your data is
in BigQuery, you
can hook it up to Data Studio
or many of the other business
intelligence suites out
there to visualize your data
and understand where
the time is being spent.
Armed with these
visualizations, you'd
know that spending
man months trying
to make your user
interface on your robot
more effective for
the picker might not
be as impactful as
maybe increasing
the speed of your
robot, or your object
avoidance, or your
slotting of your products,
because move time dwarfs
the amount of time
that it takes to pick a
product out of the box.
So there's a certain
level of insight
you could get to
with dashboards,
but to potentially move
beyond, you can try and employ
machine learning.
Machine learning might
uncover different patterns
in the data that
might not be readily
apparent with a dashboard
or visualization.
It also may help in
not only leading you
to the opportunities
for improvement,
but be the improvement itself.
You can potentially
create models
you can deploy on
a robot, and have
that robot be more effective
in its day to day job.
One of the best things
about Google Cloud
and machine learning
on Google Cloud
is you don't need an army of
data scientists or TensorFlow
developers to be able to
start to take advantage of it.
Since your data is
in BigQuery, you
can use BigQuery AutoML to
write a simple statement that,
say, returns your pick times
and all of the different facets
that might affect
that pick time.
And then with two
extra lines of code,
you can generate
a TensorFlow model
that forecasts
that pick time when
you change some of the
other parameters around it.
And just like that, you might
know the effect of the change
that you intend to
make on your system.
You can take the
same data in BigQuery
and return robot
failures and come up
with a model that gives
you predictive maintenance.
You can use none of that data
and use a pre-canned model that
would give a robot
the ability to see
whether an obstacle in
its way is human or not.
And for those of you that
aren't in the robotics space,
this is valuable
because a robot moving
very fast in close
proximity to a human
would make that human
very uncomfortable, very
understandably so.
But if a robot can't
deduce whether or not
an obstacle is
human, it would have
to slow down for every road
cone, every piece of box,
or anything in its way,
and that can dramatically
impact the pick rates.
So let's say you have your
data, it's in the cloud,
it's in BigQuery, you
have your visualizations,
and you started to
pick things that you
want to change about your
system to optimize it.
Now you're faced
with another problem,
because to be able to get
the data you need to validate
those changes are,
in fact, having
a positive impact on your
system could be costly.
You can't change the size of
your warehouse very easily,
or scale up your robot fleet
for one day to 3, 4, or 5x.
It's pretty cost prohibitive
to do things like that.
So this is where Google
Kubernetes engine can help.
You can spool up simulated
robots in simulated warehouses
and fuel BigQuery with the
same types of data you would
get if those robots were real.
That then fuels
the same dashboards
that are used to pick
what optimizations
you wanted to take.
So this is how you can
quickly validate your change
and iterate onto the next.
Now, before I hand
over to Chris,
I want to quickly
introduce 6 River Systems.
6 River was founded
on the idea that
the technological
advantages that
are seen in the large,
million square foot warehouses
by the commerce giants
should be available to all.
So not only should these robotic
systems scale up very well,
they should be
able to scale down.
Traditionally to get a fleet
of robots in a 500-1,000 square
foot warehouse, you're talking
about 6 months to 12 months.
You're talking about many, many
years before the ROI pans out.
These types of upfront costs
don't work for the 50,000
square foot warehouse.
So 6 River has a system that can
be installed and up and running
in weeks and fluctuate the size
of your fleet for peak times
and get ROI a lot quicker.
What they're trying
to do is, in effect,
democratize robotics and
level the playing field.
With that, I'll hand
it over to Chris.
CHRISTOPHER CACIOPPO:
Thank you, Paul.
So why did we decide to
use collaborative robotics
to solve a warehouse problem?
And at the end of
the day, I want
to give you a quick idea
of the problem space,
and then we'll talk about that.
Up until about 10 years
ago, distribution centers
were places where
manufacturers bought
a lot of cases of products.
They would then separate out,
and then ship it off to stores
to then fill their stocks.
So there was pretty much
moving cases from place
to place, which is
reasonably easy to automate.
They're nice and easy
to touch and square,
and it didn't require
a ton of labor.
But in the last 10 years
things have changed.
When you guys order
things online,
you never want a
case of toothbrushes.
You want a toothbrush
and a toothpaste,
maybe an iPad, some diapers.
They're all different
for everybody.
And so it requires
breaking open cases,
taking things apart, dealing
with odd-shaped items.
And so, the warehouses
look more like this.
So there are people working
on automatic hands and arms,
and you've probably
seen picking challenges,
and they always pick off
nice clean pick faces.
But it's clearly for us at least
5 or 10 years off before they
have robotic arms, they can
go in, take things apart,
pull things together,
gift wrap, all that stuff
that requires labor.
So there's tremendous
labor impact
for the foreseeable
future in this area.
To make matters worse, when I
was a kid, it was my birthday.
My mom orders off
the Sears catalog.
And we'd mail it in, and it
would take six to eight weeks
to show up, and I would've
forgotten what it was.
But I'm sure I was
excited to get it anyway.
Well in the '90s, early
2000s, shipping times
were about two weeks.
You'd order to be online
for early e-commerce,
they show up in two
weeks, everyone was happy,
it was great.
But today's day and age,
people expect things--
entry level is
two-day shipping, then
it's like one-day, and like
it'd be nice if you showed up
that afternoon.
And so, the pressure that puts
on the fulfillment centers
to get things out the
door is tremendous.
So like many things,
as latency goes down,
the efficiencies get worse.
And so, there's even
more pressure on labor.
These fulfillment centers
and distribution centers
are located in places
where land is inexpensive,
and they didn't
need a lot of labor,
but they've kind of sucked
up all the available labor.
I was with a customer about
two weeks ago and they said,
it's not so much I care
about the price of labor--
though I'm sure they do--
it's that I literally
can't get people to
reliably show up anymore.
I can't get enough people to do.
So what we've done is to
solve this problem with Chuck.
Chuck, do you want
to come over here?
So Chuck is dressed
up in its Google best.
Chuck is a collaborative
robotic robot,
and the thing I want
to point out here
is this makes the associates'
lives much easier.
But everyone in our company
is super excited about robots,
and I think most
people in this talk
would think robots
are pretty cool.
Some cameras out there.
That's pretty cool.
But people that are
often associates
working in warehouses,
robots can be
scary for a number of reasons.
And so one of the
things we did is--
when I started this, I
didn't want a little circle
or rectangle or square in a
warehouse that wasn't obvious
what it was going to do.
So I put out on my industrial
engineering hat and said,
OK, we've got a good
designer, and said,
I want this to be obvious.
So this is [INAUDIBLE]
and modeled after a car.
It's got headlights
and taillights.
It looks like a car.
And when you look
at it, no one thinks
it's going to go that way.
It's going to go that way.
And if it backs up, which
it does very rarely,
it's going to beep
and look like a truck.
So what we want to
do is get people
comfortable with the
concept so they're
comfortable [? with it. ?]
If people are not
comfortable with their
collaborative robotics,
they're not going to use it, and
nothing's going to work well.
So we've had very good
luck, and everyone
loves using our robots.
So the way a typical warehouse
works for cart pick operations,
an associate will walk
over to an [INAUDIBLE]
with a big heavy
cart, and they'll
put a whole bunch of
boxes on it and get
a whole bunch of paper
tickets and walk over
to their picking racks.
It'll look like a Costco, or
back of an Ikea, or Sam's Club,
except much more dense.
They're then going to walk
up and down a whole bunch
aisles fulfilling the orders of
these paper tickets and finding
everything where they remember.
And then they're
going to bring it
over to a take off area,
or possibly multiple ones,
and [? then ?] that big loop.
At 6 River, we decided
what's most important
that the associates can do
much better anywhere else
is the grasping the hands.
We want to try to alleviate
as much of the other stuff
they're doing as possible.
And these aren't small places.
As we talked about, these are
50k to 500k or more warehouses.
They're tremendous
amount of movement.
So what our system
does is there's
a person who sits in
an induct area on top,
and they put work on the robot,
and then the robot takes off.
The robot will then meet
someone in the picking area.
They will then walk with
them through the area
showing the pictures,
taking from place to place
in the best method possible.
And then when they're
done, that robot
will take off and deliver it
to multiple places potentially,
and then another robot
will be waiting for them.
So we'll keep them
localized in doing what they
do best in the picking aisles.
What we can do is
improve pick rates
2 to 3x over
traditional cart pick,
and we do this by
a number of ways.
We reduce the long
walks so people
don't have to walk
across giant warehouses.
We very effectively
pick orders that
go together in a nice
clean way so they
walk as little as possible.
We pick them optimally
from place to place.
And we also have
very clean UIs which
lets them get the data fast
so they can pick faster,
they can lower error rates,
and they can move training time
from weeks to hours.
And this has been hugely
positive for our customers.
The next thing about Chuck
that's very interesting
is it's a disruptive technology.
So there is a number of
technologies out there
that allow cart picking
that enhance cart picking
or replace cart picking.
But most of these operations
have three to five years ROI,
and are bolted into the floor.
And I don't know about
anyone in this audience,
but I have no idea
where my company's going
to be in three to five years.
Like, technology
changes so fast.
It is a tremendous
investment to do.
To make matters worse,
generally in this industry,
there's a huge seasonal change.
So right around holiday
season, most of our customers
see a 3 to 7x change in their
operation, tremendous changes.
So not only do you have
to predict potentially
five or more years
in the future,
but you also get the scale up so
that your operation is running
pretty much at peak, peak
time, and then 80% of your time
it's significantly
underutilized.
So what we allow to happen
is we have a two to one
year ROI for our products.
They can, instead
of being installed,
most automation is six months
to a year of installation time.
We get up and running
in one or two weeks.
It also allows you to
scale your operation.
If your operation is getting
more and more, going up and up,
you just buy more robots.
We just deliver and
they work as-is.
If your operation's
scaling down, well,
if you have another DC or
another fulfillment center,
just move the robots.
If you have seasonality, instead
of building our system from 6
River that works from your
peak for the entire year,
just build your
average for the year
and we'll lease you more
robots for your peak time.
So we have a tremendous
amount of flexibility
that is just not possible
anywhere else in the industry.
So from the first day I sat down
at my dining room table with
my two other co-founders to
the day we had a small fleet
of collaborative robots
picking live orders--
I believe it was toys--
in a customer warehouse,
was nine months, which is,
looking back on it,
felt much longer,
but it's an amazing feat.
And I don't think
this is possible
10 years ago, even with the best
group of people you could have.
And the reason is,
I think there's
three key technologies
of the last 10 years
that have made a
tremendous change.
One is ubiquitous
computing power.
So we've invested in
Nvidia's Jetson TX2 platform,
and so that gives
a tremendous amount
of processing power at
very low energy consumption
at a reasonable price point.
And so, we've done a
lot of work with them.
But it's not just that.
It's all the sensors
and all the things
that allow robotics to work
have come down tremendously
in price.
It wasn't that long ago that
the spinning [? lighters ?]
you see on top of
the Google cars--
they cost like 50 grand.
But now we can have
ones in the robots that
cost less than 1,000.
So there's a huge
change in technology
that's enabling things that
just weren't possible before.
The second one is
open source, which
I'm sure everyone here uses.
It's gotten better and better
over the last 10 years.
I want to call up ROS.
ROS is Robot Operating System,
for you non-roboticists.
It allows you to
bootstrap robots
really fast so you can
focus on the things
that your business
cares about, and not
focusing on the plumbing
and infrastructure.
So we can very quickly get
a robot up and working,
and then pile more stuff
on top to optimize it
for our environments.
And last but not least is
ubiquitous cloud platforms,
and we've embraced Google
Cloud from day one.
This allows you to
scale the operations,
leverage your
engineers we have, do
a lot of testing stuff we
have, a lot of secure things.
It just allows us to go so
much faster than we would have
otherwise.
Given the audience,
I think we'll
spend the rest of the time
talking about the Google Cloud.
So one thing that's very
important to me personally
is data-driven decisions.
Pretty much this
entire conference
is about data, and
so collecting data,
and everyone knows data is good.
But how do you use data?
How do you make it
effective for you?
So let me go through some
of the ways we use it.
And we have a lot of data,
both on the logistics side
and also from the robot side.
If you have worked
with robots, robots
generate a tremendous
amount of data
and make lots of decisions,
and it's very hard
to turn churn through
all the data otherwise.
The first thing we do is
operational intelligence.
We have a ton of data on all
of our customers' operation,
and we can tell
them how much work
they're doing, how much
time they have left,
the rates they do things,
a whole bunch of stuff.
We can say which
of their associates
are performing better and worse.
But even more than
that, instead of saying,
Chris is underperforming,
I can say,
Chris is doing pretty well.
He's just really
slow at scanning.
Maybe he doesn't how
that section works.
And so, an associate
can come to me
and help coach me
through something
that I'm weak at as opposed
to just dealing with it,
or deciding they should get
some other employee if that's
even possible.
The next thing is
visualizing data.
This is one of my
favorite things.
So this up here
is a picture of--
our robots go through the
warehouse all the time.
They report back wireless
signal strength constantly,
so every second or so.
And so, this is a map of
the wireless signal strength
at various parts of warehouse.
So people do wireless
surveys, and they're
sort of ad hoc and
occasionally [? happen. ?]
But we are
constantly, real time,
showing a wireless
survey of the warehouse.
So you can tell
in this warehouse,
there's a big area in the center
that's probably pretty weak,
and if the customer cares they
should probably update that.
But I think what's
more important is
how we use it for our internal
engineering personally.
So when you're starting to build
the robot, you get a robot,
and you get-- what we
have to do first-- you
have to make it move.
Check, it moves.
And then we don't
just want it to move,
we want it to move
from A to B. So we
want it to move over there.
Excellent, check.
We got it to move
A to B. And then
you want it not to hit things.
All right, check.
And you go through this
whole list of things,
whether it's robots
or any products
you guys do until you
get an MVP and it's
in front of the customer.
At that point, that's great.
We get some feedback and we work
on the most important things
next.
How do we choose the
most important things?
In most operations, it's
done in one of three ways.
One, the manager or
whoever's in charge decides.
Two, the loudest
engineer decides.
Or three, if you're doing
things probably correctly,
you have a consensus of
engineers that decide together.
But the problem is even
in the latter case,
where we have a
consensus, it doesn't
mean you're working on the right
thing or most important thing
first.
You just all agree.
You can all agree
on the wrong thing.
So this is a graph up
here about the time
that the associates are
spending on our product, which
is important of labor
management and labor savings.
So the big blue box
here is movement.
It says the largest
amount of time, about 44%,
is spent on the robot
moving from point A
to point B with the
associate in tow.
There are other things
down here to just scanning.
And so, one of our
engineers made a great idea.
We can just remove
scanning entirely,
and that sounds
like a great idea.
We could just skip that step.
That would be awesome.
Let's work on that.
And someone else
had an idea, says,
we can reduce movement 20%.
That doesn't sound as good,
but if you look at the numbers,
it's way better to spend
time reducing movement by 20%
than it is removing a stage,
even though it doesn't
intuitively feel
like just removing
something isn't a better idea.
So I'm going to give
an example of that.
This is another
customer warehouse,
and instead of plotting
Wi-Fi signal strength,
we're plotting average
moving speed of the robots.
So you can see red is
slower, green is faster.
So if we look at some of this
and analyze a little bit,
at the end of aisles
things are slowing down.
It makes sense.
There's cross traffic,
there's blind turns.
You got to be a lot more
careful around that.
But the slower areas in
the middle of the aisles
doesn't make a lot of sense.
Robots should be
humming along there.
It should be fine.
So we can do two things
here, and we do both of them.
One is we can push back on the
customers and say, hey, you
guys should clean this up.
The robots move faster
and your rates go up.
But really, it's better if
like-- why are we slowing down?
Like, because everybody wants
the robots to be faster.
So I think obviously the
next thing we do is just
make the robots'
top speed faster.
Or is it?
So some of our engineers
took some robots
and put them on a test track.
And instead of just reporting
the maximum speed of robots,
they report the internal
choices of robots.
And essentially a crash
course in robotics here--
we have a bunch
of different tasks
that determine how
fast a robot can go,
and the slowest one
wins, because we believe
in safety and everything else.
So whatever chooses the slowest,
that's the one that we go at.
So if you look up here, red
says I'm near an obstacle.
Yellow says go top speed.
So if you look up there and
we increase our top speed,
really wouldn't have had a giant
impact on a robot right now.
Because mostly we
[INAUDIBLE] objects,
and we're slowing ourselves
down because we're
being extra careful.
So the engineers took this
data and attacking that problem
instead of trying to make
the robot respond faster
to go faster, and
analyze that problem.
And after a couple of weeks
they did the test track again,
and this is what they got.
You'll notice instead of being
like 85% red, it's now like 40%
red.
And it's a lot of yellow,
which is the top speed.
The robot's just cruising
along at top speed.
So there was a huge impact
of diving into this problem,
and it resulted in about a
15% movement speed increase.
And now that the engineers
can look at this and say, OK,
should we keep pushing
on that problem?
Should we look at the teal over
here, which is a pathing issue?
Should we think about
raising top speed?
But it allows a
data-driven decision,
when obviously everyone says
we should just make the robots
move faster, and that was
actually the wrong decision.
So that's my part of the talk.
I'm going to hand off to Joe,
who makes all the magic happen
here.
JOSEPH HUGHES: Thanks, Chris.
So you just got hired at the
next IoT robotics company,
and you wake up the next
day and you're feeling good,
but then you think to yourself,
I need a robot infrastructure.
Lucky for you, you're
here at Google Cloud Next,
and we're going to
help you understand
how we've used Google
Cloud to address
some of the most challenging
aspects of this problem.
The first and most
obvious problem
is you have all this data.
You have hundreds of
robots in the field.
You have robots that are
in your test environments
and your customer environments.
You have to get all
this data, and you
have to make some sort
of sense out of it.
So we're going to talk about
this slide for the next 30
minutes.
You guys didn't run away.
We're not going to do that.
But I think here there's
an important thing
that I want to point out
about this architecture.
We don't just use Cloud
IoT Core for everything.
We also use Google Cloud
Storage for a couple of things.
And the reason we do that is
that there's some data that
is really important to have
in real time, but there's
other data that we may need
later that is really dense.
And Chris talked a little
bit about that data.
That's your LIDAR scans, your
point clouds, the roboticists--
if you're not a
roboticist, that's
really kind of what
the robot is seeing,
and logging all of that.
And we need to put that
into Google Cloud Storage,
because those files
are big, they're dense,
and then we need to run
it and break it down.
So we make heavy use of
Pub/Sub and Cloud Functions
to massage that data,
get it into the format
that we can consume.
Some of that data comes all the
way back through to a web page
where people can consume it.
Some of that data
goes to BigQuery,
and that's what drives some
of those interesting graphs
that Chris showed you before.
What we're going
to be doing next
is using that data in BigQuery,
as Paul alluded to earlier,
to drive some machine
learning models
so we can get better and
think more about the data
that we're collecting.
But this infrastructure
for us, this design
has survived the test of
time and scaled with us
with no engineering
intervention at all.
So one of the things that
you want from this data
is real time location.
You may think to
yourself, well, why?
That seems important.
But I'm going to explain to
you why it's very important.
If you're managing a million
square foot warehouse and you
can't have line of
sight to everything.
So you need a bird's eye
view of what's going on.
You have 25 trucks in the field.
You might have 50
employees in the field,
and you really need
that real time feedback.
So most obviously, you just
need to know where Chucks are.
If you can only see
10 Chucks at a time,
you need to know
where the other 10 are
and make sure they're
doing the things
that you expect that they should
be doing in your warehouse.
You also want to see
if Chuck's in trouble.
You'll see two Chucks
here blinking red.
If a warehouse manager was
to click on one of those,
they could see that there's
an obstacle in Chuck's way,
or that there's some other
unexpected event, maybe
some sort of maintenance that
needs to be done to Chuck.
In any case, it really
calls out very clearly
that there's a problem
that needs to be resolved.
They can get on a
radio, talk to someone,
ask them what the
problem is, or they can
make the decision to walk over.
But if you're constantly walking
around a million square foot
warehouse looking for
problems, most likely
you're not going to
be able to find them.
Lastly, you want to
understand the operation.
So if you see Chucks
queuing up in a weird way,
or you see Chucks
and your operators
are not in the right part of the
warehouse for where they need
to be at that point
of the day, then you
can correct that and make
sure that your rates--
you still hit your rates.
And that means that
everyone in the audience
gets their shoes on time, or
their toothbrushes on time,
or whatever you might be
ordering off the internet.
The next big thing that
you want from all this data
is real time monitoring.
Our customers run 24/7.
The internet's up 24/7.
People are ordering 24/7.
And you expect your
stuff in two days.
So we have a tech support
team that also runs 24/7.
And when something
comes in, they
need to really quickly respond.
Now, for our cloud software
that's running in the cloud,
Stackdriver was a clear choice.
Out of the box it
gave us alerting,
it gave us all the monitoring
that we could possibly want,
and we didn't have to
invest any engineering
time into instrumenting.
It came with the platform.
We use Google Core
IoT to feed data
and to Influx DB for a
time series database,
and then also drive
the dashboards
like you see behind me.
This gives us our CPU
metrics, our memory metrics,
and our temperature metrics.
Some of these warehouses
get up to over 100 degrees.
So the temperature of their
CPU becomes super important.
Your fan fails and
your CPU's overheating,
you're going to have
a very unhappy robot,
and eventually you'll have
a very unhappy customer.
But this really all drives
preventative maintenance.
If we can take a
Chuck out of service
before it fails and
clogs up the works,
then we can save
our customer time.
They may be running a degraded
system for a little bit.
But hopefully we can pull
the Chuck out of service,
replace a part from
our spare part kit,
and get Chuck back
in and doing its job.
Lastly, we touched on
this a little earlier,
but enabling technical
support is super important.
They're really the
front line of defense,
and they need tools to
help the customer resolve
their problems quickly and
not interrupt engineering.
If engineers are
spending all their time
solving customer
issues in the field,
then they're not going
to be able to build
the next great feature
and make Chuck better.
And we're constantly
doing the experiments,
like Chris showed you
earlier, to make Chuck faster
and to continually
raise our customer's
rates through just software and
better engineering practices.
So this is the
second type of data
that we were talking about
in that architecture slide.
This is data that's not
really valuable in real time
from every single Chuck
because it's very dense,
and it gives you the
whole picture of what
Chuck sees in the world.
But you may want
this data because you
want to replay Chuck travel.
You get something from
the field and say,
hey, Chuck is moving
strangely around this shelf,
or Chuck can't see this
particular thing on the ground,
or something of that nature.
And that comes to
our engineering team,
and we need to be
able to see that.
And so, we have two options.
We can get on a plane.
We can fly over
to the warehouse,
go take a look at Chuck and say,
oh, well, I guess I can hook in
and take a look at the sensors.
Or, maybe it's not even doing
that anymore by the time
you get there, but
planes are expensive
and engineering time
is also expensive.
Or, you can replay this Chuck
travel from Google Cloud,
you pull that down, and you
can replay in real time.
So what you're seeing
on the right of this
is you can actually see
Chuck seeing other Chucks.
On the left you can see shelves.
That's what's called
a point cloud.
You can see it's made
up of a lot of points.
From this our
engineers can deduce
a lot of interesting things.
There's your test
environment which
you have in your warehouse,
where you do all your tests
and you try really hard to make
Chuck move the right way all
the time.
Inevitably, though, you
get out into the field
and there's things
you didn't expect.
We call them movement
issues, and they're caused
by some interesting things.
Some customers shine their
floors or they have skylights,
and that feeds back
into the sensors
and makes this point
cloud much different
than it does looking at our
headquarters on our test track.
Help improve efficiency--
Chris kind of alluded
to this earlier.
But if there's a specific
place in the warehouse where
the Chucks just
always move slow,
sometimes what we can do is
clearly just see that the LIDAR
or the camera is seeing
something that it shouldn't.
And with a little
bit of adjustment
by the customer, or a
little bit of adjustment
in the map that we
use to navigate,
we can alleviate those problems.
So you have all your
data, but now you
have a hundred, a thousand, a
million robots in the field,
and you need to upgrade
them at some point.
So how do you do that?
Traditional software management,
Ansible, Saltstack, Puppet,
they're great tools
for managing servers.
You have an always great
internet connection,
and you're always--
and you can kind of rely
on the internet connection
to make things good for you.
The great white whale of
Chuck is reliable Wi-Fi.
Warehouses just don't
have reliable Wi-Fi.
There's a lot of racks,
there's a lot of interference.
And so, what we end up with
is half applied states.
So almost worse than
an upgrade just failing
is a half upgrade, an upgrade
that looks like it went good
but didn't go all the way.
And we battled a lot of
these problems early on.
So we said to ourself, there
has to be a better way.
We have to be able to reduce
the complexity of these things.
We have to be able to
minimize the amount of data
that's being pulled down,
and do it more deterministic.
So we shoehorned
everything into Docker.
Docker containers are pretty
great at solving this problem.
If you have a container, it
either downloads or it doesn't.
If you need to roll back, roll
back to a different container.
You have a very good view
of the world of where
your software is updating.
And so, if you need to
update 1,000 of these things,
all you need is a good
internet connection
to download a single file
versus what you would have
to do in the other situation,
which is a bit of a back
and forth between a lot
of different services.
We really leverage
Google Cloud's Platform
to make this possible.
And don't get scared, it's
no architecture slide,
but we're going to
go forth with it.
Google has got a lot of great
tools for building containers.
Cloud Build scales
with our developers.
As they need to make
containers and we're
rushing to finish
releases, then we
can have 20 developers doing
20 different builds and Google
Cloud Build.
It scales up, we push all those
to the container registry,
and then we have our custom
solution to this problem.
But really, Google has a great
toolkit with Kubernetes Engine
that you can run
software that just
consumes a lot of this stuff.
And finally, this software
allows us to push things out
through IoT Core.
IoT Core can't
just collect data,
but you can actually manage the
configuration of the robots.
So essentially the
message goes out to 1,
1,000, a million
robots saying, we
need you to download this
container from Container
Registry, and then
they go into action.
So I'm going to show
you how that works.
Here is an actual upgrade.
So this is sped up a little bit,
but these containers download.
The robot gets the command,
gives us the signal
that it downloaded, and then
we can apply that upgrade.
And so, you'll see me
do three at a time here.
They download and they apply.
And so, we're taking three
Chucks out of service,
we're downloading a container,
that container gets applied,
they go back into service.
But we know exactly if something
didn't work, if it did work,
and the nice thing
is going from build
X to build Y is just as easy
as going from build Y back
to build X. I think all of us
know that sometimes software
upgrades don't go well.
So almost as important
as your upgrade path
is your downgrade path.
But with Docker, Kubernetes to
drive this software, and IoT
Core, we can really manage
this problem very well.
So we have all the data.
We have thousands of robots.
And now our customer
comes and says to us,
hey, we think we need to
rearrange our entire warehouse.
We have 100 Chucks, and
we think that this design
might work better.
And you're like, OK,
well, so we're back
into kind of a problem here.
So we can either fly
out to the warehouse,
bring another 100 Chucks,
get another warehouse,
set it up the way
they want, test,
and make sure that it works, or
we have to do something else.
And I think we all kind
of realize we pretty much
just have to do something else.
So going back to our
Docker adventure here,
we were really pleased when we
got to this point when we said,
OK, we already have
everything in Docker.
So all we really
need to do is change
a few things in this
container, and we'll actually
have a Docker container that
can be run in a simulated world.
So we have the robot operating
system running completely
inside of the Docker container.
All we do is simulate
the sensor data.
And so, what's really
powerful about this
is that the sensor
data coming in
is going through
the same pipeline
that it would go through
in the real world.
So as we make adjustments,
we can be very confident
that those adjustments
are going to behave
the way that we expect
them to in the real world.
And that really just
gives us that extra bit
here where things, when
we go to deploy them,
behave the way that we want.
So why would we want to test
with hundreds of robots?
The warehouse layout
change is one thing,
but another thing is
algorithm changes.
We have a lot of
logic and algorithms,
as Chris alluded to
earlier, that batch
orders and to try to gain more
efficiencies in the warehouse.
And so, when we change
those algorithms,
it's not really great for us
to test them out on a customer.
Because you can
imagine what a customer
is going to call us and say.
They're going to call us and
say, hey, Joe, that software
upgrade you gave me--
now my rates just fell by 50%.
And that's not a really
great conversation to have,
and that's not what we want
to do for our customers.
And so, with this sort
of infrastructure,
we can prove algorithm
changes before we deploy them,
and we can confidently
tell the customer, when
you take this release, you're
going to get x number of--
x percent of improvement.
Your pickers will be
this much more efficient.
Your warehouse will be able
to get this many orders
out the door, and be
very confident that's
an accurate estimate.
And lastly, and I think-- which
is kind of an interesting way
to use the system, is that we
have cloud systems as well.
And we can do synthetic load
testing on those cloud systems
and throw foobar
data at it, or we
can run real robots,
real simulated robots,
against that system
and do load tests
for warehouses that are
even impractical to build
in the physical world.
So we can really put our
other software in the cloud
through the paces using
a very large deployment
of simulated Chucks.
So scaling with Kubernetes
Engine is super easy.
Auto scaling works
great, and that is really
important for this problem.
You don't want to have to
call up a DevOps engineer
and say, hey, I need a cluster
with 100 simulated Chucks.
You just want to
tell your software
I need 100 simulated Chucks,
and then minutes later you
have 100 simulated Chucks.
Stackdriver monitoring
is built in.
And so, you can see
your simulated Chucks
and see trends in their CPU
usage, their memory usage,
and see all that and
feed it into BigQuery,
as Paul alluded to
earlier, and make sure
that your dashboards perform
the way that they should,
and that you're seeing the
algorithm improvements that you
should.
You can scale up
and down quickly.
Scaling up is super quick.
Scaling down is
also super quick,
because this is an
expensive resource
and you don't want
to be spending money
with a simulation cluster that
someone forgot to shut down
for like a weekend, and
your Google Cloud bill
all of a sudden is a little
bit higher than you expected.
So here's a real simulation.
This is a pretend
warehouse in the cloud
with pretend robots running
around doing robot things.
They're picking orders,
they're inducting orders.
They even go to charge.
They even have
simulated batteries.
So because charging
can actually take out
of the efficiency of the system.
So we simulate all of that.
And we can put all the things
I talked about into this.
And so, this is a very,
very flexible system.
Another thing that
happens is that when
you start simulating things,
if you spawn 20 robots
in the corner of a warehouse,
they kind of form a mosh pit
and they don't
really do very well.
And so, these are
some of the fun things
that you start to discover
when you build a simulation
platform is like,
oh, wait a second,
they all can't just
spawn in one place.
They need to actually
spawn at random points,
and we need to
kind of figure out
how we scale this up and down.
But yeah, that's a fun little
video of a robot mosh pit
if you ever wanted to see one.
So the last thing we
need to talk about
is integrating with
your customers.
You didn't just build
this robotic IoT
platform for yourself.
You built it because you
wanted to bring it to the world
and you want people to use
it and companies to use it.
And so, you have
to kind of discover
who your customers are,
discover what kind of technology
they have, and you have
to integrate with it.
So in warehouse
management systems
are the systems that
handle all the orders,
handle all the inventory.
They kind of determine what that
day's picking is going to be,
and they give us our work.
And so, we have to
integrate with them.
Our customers have
older systems.
They're in the
logistics business.
They're not in the IT
or the tech business.
And so, when they find a
solution that works for them,
they stay with that solution.
And we don't want to
go into our customers
and say, well, we wish
we could work with you,
but you have to update
all of your IT systems
to adhere to REST
standards into our APIs.
We have to do
something different.
So we adapt our
ears our REST APIs
to our customers' technology.
They use Socket communication
with fixed-width messages.
They use SOAP.
They use SFTP.
I mean, they use everything.
And so, that means we
have to build everything
and we have to adapt
our APIs to everything.
And so, that's a big
challenge, but luckily,
when you're using
Google Cloud Platform,
you have a lot of tools at
your fingertips to help you
with that challenge.
We reach for cloud functions for
the simplest of integrations,
and Kubernetes also makes
super quick with things like
[? Hey ?] [? Native ?] and
other tools that are coming
to the Kubernetes platform
where we can build these little
micro-services that their only
purpose in life is to translate
our API messages so that our
customers can understand them.
There's a lot of challenges
still, but with these tools--
without these tools
we wouldn't be
able to do what we do today
at the pace and at the scale
we do it today.
Google Kubernetes Engine
on-prem is the next great thing
that 6 River systems
is really looking at.
And some of our customers
have such tight regulation--
you can think government
and those type of things,
where they just
don't have the option
to have anything outside
of their four walls.
And so with these
type of deployments,
we're really excited
to experiment
and to use Google
Kubernetes on-prem to solve
these problems.
So these regulation concerns
are definitely one part of it.
Another part is bringing
latency sensitive things that
need to happen to the edge, and
the edge being the customer's
own infrastructure.
And so, if we have to validate
something every single time
we scan it and we can't afford
the trip up to our cloud,
back to their data
center, back to Chuck,
then a system like
this makes things
a lot easier for the
customer and for us
to get that integration done and
to really have a great customer
experience.
From our point of
view, it's so great
that we can have the same
deployment tooling that
manages all of our
normal cloud deployments
manage these on-prem
deployments as well.
And so, that can reduce our
overhead for DevOps tooling,
and to keep the
interface that we
use for our software engineers
and for our tech support
engineers the same.
[MUSIC PLAYING]